Welcome back. So now that you already know what kind of fundamental data structures you have which
are native to python basically data structures that you can directly take for granted in python
we are in this video going to introduce a library called pandas. Pandas stands for panel data
analysis which basically uses lists dictionaries and arrays from python or numpy to create something
called a data frame. A data frame is a supercharged data storage structure which is available through
pandas and you can think of it as excel for python so if you know how to use pandas very well you
should be able to do pretty much everything that excel can do and more in a programmatic pythonic
way. So let's get started first of all in order to run the notebook we'll have to import a bunch of
modules so we are basically going to import pandas and we're also going to do some
plotting so we are going to import the plotting library which is called matplotlib
let's run that so essentially pandas lets us read process and analyze any kind of tabular data
so when we say read what we mean is that pandas has parsers for multiple different file formats
you can read from csv files you can read from excel sheets you can read from databases
and so many other sources you can process that data once you have taken care of the file io not
only can it read from all of these different formats it can actually also write back to all
of these different formats so it takes care of files file io as well as it can do the processing
of the data which is basically most of the bulk of pandas functionality essentially processing
cleaning manipulation and all of that and finally it also has a few things which we can use for
analysis this is where things get into the mathematics and statistics part so the univariate
bivariate multivariate analysis techniques that we have briefly covered in an earlier video you'll
see that most of them are doable right within pandas so the primary entry point into pandas is
like i said data frame so let's take a look in a little more detail on what a data frame is
in general you can just consider a data frame as the python equivalent of
excel sheet so these are basically labeled two-dimensional data structures what do we
mean by two-dimensional data structures is that we saw that we had lists which were simply indexable
by a certain position that is if you had to access a particular value in a list you only had to know
its position whereas most of our data as you know is going to be tabular so you can access a particular
cell value by its row position as well as its column position and these don't even have to be
positions we have to have them as you know we can have them as names not necessarily integers
or numbers so that's what we mean by saying that it's a labeled two-dimensional data structure what
it means is that the rows have their own labels columns have their own labels just like a dictionary
has labels and values against them or keys and values against them pandas rows are also like
dictionaries and columns are also like dictionaries you're going to see that in a little more detail
in just a little bit and it's basically in spirit very similar to an excel worksheet or a relational
database table so essentially pretty much whatever you can do with rows and columns is what you can
do with pandas and by now we have also spoken in quite some amount of detail about the details of
tabular data but let's also revise it just for the sake of completeness so we know that
each row represents one sample out of all the data points that you've collected each column
contains a different variable that describes the sample or which is rows essentially each column is
an attribute of the thing that you're measuring and the data in every column is usually the same
data type that is if you're measuring somebody's height then the whole column is more likely to
contain numbers rather than strings and so on so that's basically what creates a data frame it's
essentially just a table and can be created in many ways such as using another data frame or you
know using a numpy array or a composite of arrays that has two dimensional shapes so as we've seen
in the previous video we have a bunch of two dimensional shapes for example the nested list
example if you remember which was a list of lists and each internal list had the same amount of
elements in it so that represents a table at the same time a dictionary which has keys as the column
headers and the values as lists which contain the column values that also represents essentially a
two-dimensional data set which can be used to create a data frame you can use a panda series
also now a series is essentially just one column or one row of a data frame so if a data frame is
a two-dimensional structure a series is essentially it's one-dimensional equivalent within the pandas
ecosystem it can be produced from a file such as a csv file or an excel file it can be also
created from a table and we have already covered how it can be created from a dictionary so these
are some common operations with pandas let's say that this is one particular data set that we have
which contains again it's actually a dictionary so you can tell that from the braces we haven't
closed a bunch of things within braces which means that it's a dictionary we have keys colon
values so essentially this is a dictionary which has three key value pairs the first is name the
second is score and the third is attempt and if you look at the values of each of these keys they
are essentially lists of the same length whatever is the length of this particular well sequence of
names that is the same as the length of the sequence of scores and of the attempts and let's
say that we have another list which is just a list of letters from a to j so that's 10 and all
of these are also 10 so essentially these are interpreted by pandas as column headers and the
values of a given column we can just put the dictionary within the pd.dataFrame caller over
here and we can say that we want the index to be these labels so let's just run that and we see
that we get a data frame this is essentially our data which is tabular and we saw that name
which was a key became a column header score which was another key became the next and attempts became
the last and the values inside each of these values they became the contents of the column itself
now here's how you do some of the common operations within a data set this is the whole
data set containing 10 rows if we just want to see the top few rows we can just do a df.head
now df.head by default when you call it it's going to show us the top five rows but we can
give it any number over here i can say just show me the top two rows or i can say show me all 10
rows or i can just say show me eight rows so i can just pass it an integer and it's going to show me
the top k columns or the top k rows of a particular data frame the same thing i can also do using an
iloc function iloc is essentially integer location so essentially i'm saying that give me the first
three rows and that's it so that basically gives me the first three rows this is how you can slice
out different rows of a data frame in order to get a column i can just remember the data frames
also act like dictionaries so essentially just like you get a key value pair from a dictionary
this is how you get a column from a data frame this is going to give me the score column out of
the data set which as you see is 12.5 9.0 16.5 all the way up to 7.5 so let's try that
and there it is you see in both those cases whenever we try to get a row the index which
is abcdef all the way up to j remains the same what that means is that each location
instead of being indexed by a number is being indexed by a letter right so that simply is
useful because sometimes strings or names are easier to remember than numbers so just like in
a list you have positioning by numbers here you can have positioning by arbitrary strings so those
are called the index of a data frame you can also filter a column which says that you know let's say
i want somebody whose name is emily and i want to take that person's score so we know that there
is exactly one row which has name as emily and i want to get this particular value operator so
i can use that as a filter i can say that filter the data frame df such that the name column equals
emily and from that get the score out so there it is that basically gives me the score of emily
easier way to break that down would be something like this let's say that i simply do df.name
equal to equal to what this is going to return is a set of boolean values which is whether the name
is emily whether the name is emily for this particular row and for that row or not and
essentially there is only one row where it is true and when i use this to slice my data frame
in general it's basically going to give me all those rows where the name is emily in this case
it's just one row so that gives me the first row the only row which contains the name as emily
and out of this like we know this is how we get a score or we get a particular column out
we get the column so there it is it's basically 9.0 and here's how we edit a cell when you want
to change the particular value in a cell we just do an loc operation on it which stands for location
so what this instruction says is that find the location d and then find the column score and
set its value to something so what this means is that in my original data frame the d column is
james and the score is 6.0 what i'm going to do is score set the score to 11.5 so when we do this
operation sorry when we do this operation and look at the data frame again we'll see that the score
of james is going to be 11.5 so let's try that there it is so we see that the score of james
has become 11.5 in order to do that remember what we had to do was find the index value which was d
and find the score or the column that we wanted to change and we just assign the desired value
to this output we have already seen some examples of logical filtering but let's take a look at some
of them again let's say that we want to take all the elements or all the rows of the data frame
where the score is greater than 15 or less than or equal to 20 in the sense that we want to find
all the scores all the people who scored between 15 and 20 marks both values included so what we
are saying is that create a boolean value just like we had a boolean value over here
which contains true for all the scores which are greater than or equal to 15 and do do an
logical and with another set of boolean values which have a score of less than or equal to 20
so when we run this we see that katherine michael and jones are the only three people who got scores
between 15 and 20 and if you verify this from the data you will see that it is actually correct
the next step would be to do some sort of arithmetic on the column this is useful when
we are trying to calculate our univariate statistics or aggregations and grouping which
we will consider later in this particular video you can just take the column remember that this
is how you access a column and call a sum or a mean on it so let's say the total number of attempts
is basically 90 so this is how you can do it and if you try to take the average score of the entire
batch that's 12.75 now in order to motivate some of these examples further what we are going to do
is look at a case study so kaggle is an online platform which runs competitions which runs
basically data science competitions if you go to this compete tab over here you will see that there
are a bunch of competitions that kaggle hosts essentially what they do is that if a company
has a lot of data but they don't know what to do with that data and they want that data analyzed
or they want some sort of predictive models built with that data they will host a competition for
that in exchange for a fee from the company and what what they do then is that they invite
practitioners such as yourself to compete on these data sets to come up with a best possible model
and whoever is the winner gets a little prize from the organizers and from kaggle and the
organizers get the algorithm and the winner gets the money so that's how basically this works it's
also you know a way of crowd sourcing solutions and what they do is that this is by the way a
very well known data science platform a lot of data sets are available here a lot of competitions
are available here it's also you know quite addictive in a way because people can waste a
lot of time on this so what they do is that they conduct a survey every year where they talk to
all the people who are enrolled on the kaggle platform and they talk to those people about their
preferences and what sort of working environment they have what sort of jobs they do do they use
machine learning or not if they use machine learning audit analysis what algorithms they
use what software they use a bunch of different things so essentially what we're going to do in
this particular case study is take the data from this survey and try to see what sort of analysis
we can do on that so essentially this is the file which contains the survey results let's read that
file it's a csv file which means it's a comma separated value file we are going to use the
read csv function again included with pandas to read that data into a data frame and let's
as we know the head function is going to give us the top five rows let's take a look at that
so there it is so this basically is our header it says that i have i'm looking at five rows because
i called df.head without any function and it gives me five rows by default i can change that
whenever i want and it has 246 columns why it has 246 columns is because the survey contains
a lot of questions it's a fairly involved and a fairly detailed survey it'll take about a good
half an hour to 45 minutes for somebody to sit down and finish the survey but at the same time
it's very valuable because this is a good way for the data science and the data analytics community
to get more information out there about themselves and about the different opportunities and what
sort of work people do and so on so as we see the very first column essentially is time from start
to finish in seconds and every row is basically one respondent of the survey so basically whoever
this person was that person took 510 seconds to fill the survey and their age was between 20 and
24 years of 22 and 24 years that person was a male and this is one particular question that
they did not choose to answer because this was basically what is your gender and you know the
option here is prefer to self-describe since they've already sent their mail
they wouldn't want to take this particular option they live in france they have a master's degree
they the job title is software engineer they work in a company where there are about thousand to
ten thousand employees and so on so that's basically the data set that we have so let's take a you know
a little bit of time in trying to understand the data you already know the shape of the data there
are nineteen thousand seven hundred and eighteen surveys by the way when you call df dot shape on
a particular data frame it's going to give you two numbers the first will always be the number of
rows and the second will always be the number of columns here also we can see that we have five
rows and 246 columns but that's because we only did df dot head and that only lets us see five
rows at a time so the overall number of rows is nineteen thousand seven hundred and eighteen which
means that in this survey nineteen thousand seven hundred and eighteen data analysts from all over
the world participated now they will not necessarily identify data as data analysts but nineteen
thousand seven hundred and eighteen kaggle users participated in the survey so and we have 246
columns which are basically a combination of multiple questions that were asked in the survey
and all the possible answers that you could have given to that survey so let's take a look at this
how do we interpret the dimensions of this data well it's obvious there are nineteen hundred seven
nineteen thousand seven hundred and eighteen participants and there are 246 response columns
each row is a question in the survey this option is clearly not correct it is a participant's
response to the survey essentially and each column is essentially a question in the survey
and also you know the set of all answers given to a given to a given question so basically this
column the third column is essentially the genders of all the people who have participated in this
particular survey right so how do we get the rows let's say that i want to just get the first row
so i set i equal to zero and i do df dot log of i so that's my first row now you see there is
something really funny with this data set the headers are there and then in the first line
we have the header again essentially you see you have things like q1 q2 q2 other text q3 q4
so essentially the header is basically a bunch of codes that are given to the question whereas
in the first row you see that that is the verbatim verbose version of the whole question this is the
question the text of the question as it appeared in the survey itself why they have given codes
is that because you know the questions might become too long and therefore it might just be
easy to deal to refer to them with codes right so there is our first column it's basically the
code and the meaning of that question essentially the question code and the question itself that's
the pairing we have here now how do we get a list of columns from a data frame we just do a df dot
columns so the columns attribute of the data frame variable which is df is just going to give me all
the columns that we have and these are all the columns we have we have see time taken from start
to finish q1 q2 q2 other text q3 q4 q5 q5 had other text because you know sometimes you have
questions and surveys where it's an mcq kind of a question but at the same time there'll be a field
called other or something like that where you can add in free text instead of choosing one of the
predefined choices that are given to you so that's basically captured under the other text column
for that particular question and then there are multiple questions which are you know in multiple
parts so for example we can see here that question 34 had 12 parts so we have we can see that there
was part four five six some of them are not shown here because this is a list which has 246 elements
in it and python chooses not to show it we can actually of course convert it to a list
and actually see the whole list but that would be too long to pass and that's why it's more or less
meaningless you can just look at the columns to get a summary idea of whatever number of columns
there are so we have we the point is that there are questions and some of them have multiple
choice answers and some of them also have text free text answers essentially so we know how to
select a particular column we just say that my column name is time from start to finish in seconds
and i just do i just get that column out by putting a bunch of putting a pair of square brackets
around it and calling it on the dictionary just like you get a key value pair out of a dictionary
similarly you get a column out of a data frame so basically i know that my column is time from start
to finish in seconds i put that string in a variable called call name and i just access the
call name from the data frame and that's it so i see that the zero value is duration and seconds
the first value is 510 and so on blah blah blah right so basically that's the
time that every participant took to finish the survey now here's a question
how is this column useful to somebody who is analyzing this data we want to analyze this data
we want to figure out what are the interesting patterns that are available within this data set
which is coming from the responses of data science practitioners from all over the world
so clearly there is a lot of inherent value on this we might want to see
what are their preferences how much do they earn what are their qualifications and so on
a bunch of those things are there so one of the columns we're considering first
is the time column the duration think a bit about how this might be useful
feel free to pause the video and when you have thought about it when you have say a couple of
ideas about how a duration might be useful in analyzing this data resume the video
well if you think about it these are survey results and unfortunately most of us do not
take surveys very seriously we either just submit them if they are short enough and if
it's convenient for us but otherwise we just skip past them and you know that evidence for that can
be seen here you see that there are people who have finished the survey in 83 and 84 seconds
which is just even less than two minutes it's barely one and a half minutes so for a survey
that has about 246 data points to capture about you there is no way that you can finish that
survey properly in 83 or 84 seconds some of the other values yeah they do look a little
reasonable but at the same time we see that we have terribly large values as well 9,195 seconds
so these are probably people who opened up the survey in a browser tab and then forgot about it
and only later remembered it and then submitted the survey so you know what's happening here is
that we have people who either just opened the survey and ignored it completely or people who
opened it and forgot about it with of course a bunch of values in between so let's take a look
at what are the minimum and maximum values in this particular column and that raises an error
let's take a look at the error it basically says that less than or equal to is not supported
between instance of string and it so it's essentially in order to calculate the minimum
or the maximum somewhere internally it has to perform this less than or equal to operation
and it says that it's not supported between instances of string and it's what it means
is that it doesn't know how to compare strings and ends it you know if you give it a pair of
two integers then it knows one of them is greater than or equal to the other or not
but when some of the columns are strings that goes for a toss it doesn't know how to compare
strings and integers and why is this happening well look at you know if we can think take a look
at the first row you see that the first row is a string and everything else is a number so what
we need to do in order to find the minimum and maximum is basically to omit this particular row
and look only at the remainder of rows so let's try that so when we see df.head we see that
entire first row for all the questions is basically just the question reworded in the sense that our
original header is basically just text and the first row is just you know another piece
of text which actually contains the whole questions and the real data of the survey
starts from the first row onwards not from the zeroth row so what we need to do is omit this
whole row and somehow keep a mapping to the headers themselves so in order to debug this error that
we got say it says that it's a type error which means a type error usually occurs in pythons when
you're trying when you're trying to do operations on things that don't have the correct type for it
and that is actually true over here so when you do a less than or equal to it is only supported
between two numbers not between a number and a string so that's why the type of the variables
that you are passing to this operation were incorrect so let's take a look at the type of
this particular column it says that it's an o type o stands for object over here what that means is
that it's not a integer or it's not a float it's not a boolean it's a string type why that has
happened is because the first row contained a string so that is why it casted everything
else into a string as well it did not stop to interpret all of these things as numbers
now if we say that duration is simply the call name from the first element onwards if you remember
this is the syntax we use for slicing lists in python so when i say one colon what that means
is that take everything from the first row onwards so let's try that and put that in a new variable
called duration so when we take do ahead on duration you see that we have a bunch of things
which are now numbers we have gotten rid of the very first column which was text right
and now what we're going to do is use this function called pd.tume to numeric to convert
this d type of object into a d type of integer let's try it we see this time we get it correctly
it shows me the data but at the same time it's also telling me that the type is int64 what int64
means is that each integer is being represented with 64 bits right so one way to do that is
actually to apply a lambda function lambda functions in python are nothing but anonymous
functions they are essentially functions that take a particular value and whatever you write
next to it that is the value that they return so essentially it takes an x and it converts that x
into an integer and returns it so what i do is i apply this particular function to each row of
duration using the dot apply method so essentially duration here is my column and when i do a dot
apply of this particular function what is going to do is simply take this function and apply it
to every single row of that column and that output i'm capturing in a variable called duration in
it which is my integer duration so there it is so again as we see when i do a head on the output
column i get the time from start to finish in integers one easier way to do that is simply to
duration dot as type of integer i can also do an as type of float but in this case we just
we are just measuring seconds there is no concept of you know half second or something like that
so integers is fine so let's take a look at this now now we have
yeah that's basically the column we have which has a type of integer 64
now for the first time in all of this exercise for the first time we have a column which is
purely numerical and as you know what we do with numerical columns is do univariate analysis on them
and one of the straightforward graphical methods of doing univariate analysis is to try and build
a histogram so essentially let's do just that that is that's basically the histogram of our data
that can be done simply by calling the dot hist function on any column in pandas so basically
this was a column duration index and we just called it just called the hist function on it
and we gave a parameter which is the number of bins that we want to divide the data into
if you remember correctly the histogram what it does is that it takes the minimum value the maximum
value and that range it divides equally into a bunch of bins and for each bins it's just going
to count how many values lie within that bin so essentially we're saying that take the minimum
value take the maximum value divide it into 50 equal bins and try to just count how many
rows there are within each bin so as we can see from the histogram lots of values most of them
in fact or 90 percent and more easily are concentrated in the very first one so which
means that there are obviously a few outliers some people took a lot of time to a very small
number of people but they did take a lot of time to fill the data set right so in order to make a
little more sense of this particular histogram we are barely getting any information here all
we're getting from this particular histogram is that most of the data is concentrated in the
leftmost bin or the minimum bin of my data in order to see a little more clearer histogram what
we're going to do is filter the data along this axis a little bit and look at the histogram when
we have a smaller range of numbers so as we know we can do the filtering with Boolean indices
if you remember how we filtered the name of Emily from the earlier example we had we added
basically a logical condition like a double equal to operator and it returned a bunch of true and
false values and we use those true and false values to pick rows from the data set right and
that's exactly what I'm going to do over here we say that find those rows in duration and ends such
that their value is less than 60 so we are basically trying to find out all the people who
submitted or finished the survey in less than 60 seconds and from that we are going to calculate
the histogram so let's take a look at this so there it is we see that about a little less than
10 people finished it in 25 seconds and about 50 or so people finished it in less than 60 seconds
now the thing is that all of these people probably didn't take the survey very seriously so this is
you know this is some data we might have to drop because they probably just randomly clipped
something and in general there since they finished such a complicated survey very quickly
their input is not very reliable so essentially now we are going to use these filters to filter
out the entire data set so what we do is we create a new column called to drop which is simply going
to contain the index values of all those peoples whose duration was less than 60 seconds so let's
do that and when we look at the to drop function created thus we see that row number 100 and 451
700 7844 10 526 all the way up to 1 919 706 these are basically the row positions
whose duration was less than 60 seconds so if we go back to the data we see that we have these
numbers 0 1 2 3 as our row labels now these are the row labels such that their duration in
integers was less than 60 and these are the ones that we have to drop in order to do that we use
the drop method which is also available on the data frame itself so what i say is df.drop and
then i give it the values to drop which is essentially the list of these values and i say
that drop them along the 0th axis the 0th axis basically means that i want to drop them along
the rows not the columns so essentially the 0 axis is since it's a two-dimensional data frame it has
two axis and since counting starts from zero the 0th axis is the rows and the first axis is the
columns so we want to drop along this along this particular axis those values don't exist at all
it's the column headers that exist right so we can think of this as a little bit of data sanitization
and we want to do it in place we want to modify the existing data frame to drop these values we
don't want to create a new data frame right so we just add that in place equal to true flag over
here which is just going to drop all of that data and then when we do df.head we see that we have
all the values that are greater than 60 in fact when we try to do
first of all if we get the call name we get the data again and then when i try to do an iloc of
one onwards which is all of these things without worrying about this particular
value which is actually a text and therefore might prevent me from calculating minimums
and maximums then i'm going to convert it into integers and then i'm going to take a minimum
value and as we see the minimum value is 60 which means that we are only keeping those people in our
data who have submitted who have taken at least one minute to submit the survey now of course this
choice of 60 seconds is arbitrary you can easily say that you know how do we know that somebody who
did not finish it in one second or one minute one second was actually not you know was taking
it seriously so this is a completely arbitrary value you can choose your own the idea is just
to show you how we can do filtering and use that filtering to drop particular rows which you think
might be unclean now we're going to continue with this data set in the next notebook and in order to
do that we are going to save the clean data that we have they're just going calling it clean because
we have dropped some rows which you know by some definition we have designated as dirty or suspicious
suspicious rows in order to save a file or a data frame to a file just like we did a read csv
there is also a two csv you just give the path to the file that you want and you say that index is
false which simply means that this particular column which is our index column we don't want
to write it back because it's just zero one two three there's no point writing it back
it's just going to infer it back from the data when we read it again so let's write that data
now our data is written and make sure that you actually finish this step properly because we are
going to depend on this clean data in the next video when we do more mathematical and more
statistical analysis on this data set